. so schnell ist. Stefan T ist dabei! Nee, es ist ein Problem, was leider besteht. Ich freue mich sehr, dabei sein zu dürfen nach wie vor, dass du mir diese Möglichkeit jede Woche aufs Neue gibst. Mit dabei ist auch Florianthin Will und mit dabei war auch Julius. Vielen Dank für das fantastische Intro. Vielen Dank für die Intros, die immerhin immer noch weiter kommen. Ja. Also wir werden, wir haben eine ganze Weile noch Intros in der Hinterhand. Ja, wir haben eine Menge Intros. Wir haben eine richtig Menge Intros. Haben wir zu viele Intros, eure Team? Vielleicht haben wir zu viele Intros, vielleicht müssen wir irgendwann anfangen, so drei, vier Intros zu spielen oder mehrere pro Folge. Irgendwann bestehen Folgen nur noch aus Intros auch. Finde ich auch immer nicht schlecht. Ich finde die tausendste Folge, da haben unsere Hörer auch was Besonderes verdient, kriegen die einfach sehr viele Intros aneinander geschnitten. Ich mag Intros eher am liebsten. Bei Filmen finde ich immer den Anfang am besten. So die ersten zehn Minuten sind immer das Beste. Bei mir ist es immer bei mir ist immer der erste Akt. Wobei es eigentlich keinen Sinn macht, weil der zweite Akt ist ja der Fun-and-Games-Akt. Der ist ja der, wo das Poster entsteht. Weißt du, das Filmposter. Das ist ja das, was in der Mitte passiert. Im zweiten Akt. Dritter Akt, hinten raus, stell ich mir so einen Jongleur vor, der irgendwie versucht, diese ganzen Bälle in Luft zu halten und irgendwie diese roten Fäden einzusammeln und am Ende dann, weil er mit Wollknollen jongliert in diesem weirden Bild, was ich auch mache, verheddert ist und dann trotzdem irgendwie zum Ende kommen muss und dann irgendwann abspann halt. Aber deswegen sind Ende immer unbefriedigend, sind nie richtig geil. Nee, irgendwie bin ich auch bei Ende nicht so drin und es ist oft ja eigentlich unfair, weil viele Filme ein schlechtes Ende haben und man dann den ganzen Film nur nach dem Ende bewertet und dann gibt man raus und ist enttäuscht.
Oh spannend, Gehirnforscher, Neurologen kann man auch sagen, die haben herausgefunden, dass man Filme auf eine total blöde Art und Weise bewertet als Mensch.
Und zwar bewertet man die nur nach dem emotionalen Höhepunkt für einen, also wo man emotional am meisten invested war in der Story, wo am meisten passiert, und nach dem Ende. Diese beiden Dinge. Mehr kann sich das Gehirn nach so einer dreistündigen The Irishman Sitzung gar nicht merken als der grösste emotionale Höhepunkt und das Ende. Aber da musste dann irgendein armes Schwein wahrscheinlich einen kompletten Film in so einer Magnetröhre anschauen. Und dann hat man gemessen, wann die Person lacht und nicht. Und das ist natürlich eine angespannte Situation irgendwie so. Ich denke mir auch immer so, dann gibt es ja, wo man dann Spiele spielen muss, irgendwie in dieser Röhre und man denkt sich, ah, komm, ha ha ha, ha ha, man weiß nicht, man übertreibt so ein bisschen. Ich glaube, deswegen braucht man sehr, sehr grosse MRTs oder was ist noch,, CTs, sehr, sehr grosse, die so hausgross sind oder ein Haus aus MRT. Und dann kann man da drinnen eine relativ normale Situation irgendwie herstellen, normale Bedingungen, normale Filmguckbedingungen, sagt den Leuten nicht, dass sie in einer großen MRT-Röhre sind eigentlich. Und dann geht der Film los und draußen sind da sehr laut auch leider MRT-Röhren. Brrrrm, brrrm, geht es dann lautlos, aber zumindest die Grösse. Aber wer sagt eigentlich nicht, dass das natürliche Nord-Süd-Magnetfeld der Erde ein riesiges MRT-Gerät ist, in dem wir alle leben, das wir nicht wissen, und in dem wir eigentlich Marktforschung betreiben für irgendeine Alienrasse, die uns als die gleichgültigste Rasse identifiziert hat und für die machen wir Produktforschung, dass wenn wir sagen, ah, diese Hitchies, diese kurzen Gummikaustäbchen, die kommen gut an bei den Menschen, die bringen wir jetzt auf Smog, auf Hitchler, auf Smog bringen wir die jetzt auf dem Markt und auf Smog haben alle diese Hitchies, weil wir die getestet haben, wie die eine Stadt in Deutschland, die alles testet. Ja, die durchschnittlichste Stadt Deutschlands. Wir sind vielleicht der durchschnittlichste Planet des ganzen Universums. Wir haben Krieg und so Dinge, die man ausprobieren muss. Wir beeinflussen, glaube ich, viel mehr, als man denkt mit unseren Metern. Ja, und ich hatte auch so ein Professor gesagt, dass wir, es ist viel wahrscheinlicher, dass wir in einer Simulation leben, als dass wir nicht in einer Simulation leben. Aber jetzt mal ganz kurz, wie wahrscheinlich ist es, dass man in der Simulation einen Professor hat, der sagt, dass es eine Simulation ist?
Ja, aber wann ist sie vorbei? Oder wer beobachtet die Simulation? Müsst du nicht jetzt, müssen wir nicht ein Signal bekommen, so ihr seid auf dem richtigen Weg oder so?
Ja, so ein Leckerli fällt aus dem Himmel, direkt dem Professor auf den Kopf.
Oder so ein Riesenknochen, so ein Riesen, wie man es kennt, Whers-artig, so ein Leckerli und löscht
die von hinten aus, weil es zu gross ist.
Aber das finde ich sehr lustig,
weil es eine Begründung war, wir sind ja jetzt schon,
also erstmal ist die Menschheit sehr interessiert
daran, Simulationen zu erschaffen,
Computersimulationen zu erschaffen.
Und das ist ja ein Beweis daran,
dass alle Lebensformen irgendwann dieses Interesse hegen.
Ist wirklich die gesamte Menschheit daran interessiert,
Simulationen zu erschaffen? Nein, aber die Menschheit an sich arbeitet ja daran auch. Wirklich? Ich habe ehrlich gesagt da noch nichts dazu beitragen. Ja, es wird nicht ignoriert. Gut, also du hast rotiert deine Aussage von sie sehr interessiert bis es wird nicht ignoriert. Alles klar, gut, weiter geht's. Also irgendwo in diesem Spektrum arbeitet die Menschheit an Simulationen und ist schon sehr weit, darauf wollte ich eigentlich hinaus, ist schon sehr weit. Mit GTA 5 ist man fast schon da. Man war schon da. Man hat New York einmal simuliert, so richtig. Und dann hat er gesagt, weil wir halt jetzt schon am Anfang unseres Stadiums, obwohl wir noch nicht so lange auf der Erde sind, schon so weit sind mit Simulationen, ist es sehr wahrscheinlich, dass wir irgendwann so weit sind, dass wir Leben kreieren können als Simulationen. Und das ist ja nichts anderes als das, was dann mit uns passiert ist in dieser These. Gut, aber die Menschheit interessiert sich auch sehr viel Fritteusen. Das heißt ja nicht notwendigerweise, dass wir in einer Fritteuse leben. Doch, wir sind eine grosse Fritteuse. Du bist Fritteuse, ich bin Fritteuse. Reicht es reine Interesse aus, um zu sagen, deswegen leben wir darin? Nein, aber der Fakt, dass wir schon sehr reelle Bedingungen schaffen können für Simulationen und immer weiter daran arbeiten, legt nahe, dass wir irgendwann Leben erschaffen werden, simuliert. Und deswegen ist es sehr wahrscheinlich, dass wir auch aus Simulationen entstanden sind. Ich habe jetzt keine Meinung dazu. Ich habe ja keine Stakes in dieser Diskussion. Ich sehe gerade nur diese Alienrasse, die gerade genau uns zuschaut und sie denkt so weiter, weiter, ja. Und das bedeutet was? Nächster Schritt. Und bei dir sagen alle immer, bei dir ist immer ein grosser Facepark, weil du immer sagst, ja, wir können ja Fritteuse leben und die ganze Alien-Rasse, die uns gerade live zu schlussendet, die ganze Zeit, oh Gott, kann dir mal jemand weg? Streichen so mit grossen Eddings die Fritteusentheorie von ihrer Tafel einfach weg. Aber irgendwo in so einem Multiversum sind wir wahrscheinlich, gibt es uns auch als Fritteusen. Vielleicht sind wir so im Grand Canyon. Nee, wie heißt das, wo die vier Gesichter sind? Was? Ich war gerade noch bei einem Bild, wo Fritteusen uns frittieren. Ach so. Gut. Hat jemand schon mal versucht, eine Fritteuse zu frittieren? Ist man da weitergekommen in der Forschung? Ich glaube, dann bricht die Simulation zusammen. Das ist der Moment. Das ist so ein bisschen wie wenn man einen Huhn mit Hühnerfleisch füttert. Dann wird es irgendwann weird irgendwie. Es wird irgendwann auch moralisch verwerflich. Hast du die neuen Rick and Morty-Folgen geschaut? Ich habe die erste Folge geschaut, die zweite noch nicht, weil ich habe Bock, das ein bisschen aufzusammeln und dann so ein bisschen wegzurutschen. Es gibt schon drei. Ich bin auch kein Fan von diesem wöchentlichen Erscheinen. Das ist doch bei Star Wars so. Nee, funktioniert für mich nicht. Ja, manchmal bei manchen Serien lasse ich mich da gerne gängeln und denke mir, oh ja, gib mir mehr, lass mir noch einen Krümel vom Tisch runterfallen, bitte, oh, ich will noch ein Leckerli, ich will noch ein Leckerli. Bei manchen sage ich aber einfach, nee, ich komme in der Woche nochmal.
Und dann eigentlich alles.
Das ist auch so, wenn Filme im Kino sind, hat man total Bock, die zu sehen, aber man sitzt andererseits total oft vor dem Problem, dass man nicht weiss, welchen Film man anschauen soll, obwohl alle Filme, die auf Netflix sind, ja irgendwann mal im Kino waren. Und da wollte man sie unbedingt anschauen und jetzt nicht mehr irgendwie. Ich denke immer so, ich versuche mal nachzudenken, welchen Film wollte ich unbedingt im Kino sehen, den ich jetzt sehen kann, aber dann fällt mir nichts ein. Ich bin wirklich so verzweifelt auf Netflix, weil man einfach nichts Vernünftiges auf Netflix anschauen kann. Da gibt es keine guten Serien, da gibt es keine guten Filme. Alles, was es gibt, hat man schon lange durch. Vor drei Jahren war ich mal cool. Aber mittlerweile nur noch Crap und diese Eigenproduktion. Ja, es wird halt nicht produziert, aber auf der anderen Seite... Und deswegen war ich so verzweifelt bei Netflix, dass ich umgestiegen bin auf Netflix Kids. Ich bin jetzt häufiger auf Kids als im normalen Netflix. Ich glaube, da laufen wir auch. Aber da wurden alle Drogen immer verpixelt, mit so grossen Emojis und so. Und immer wenn MDMA fällt, wird es gegen, weiß ich nicht, Paw Patrol ausgetauscht oder so. Ja, ja. Und ich schaue jetzt Tim und Struppi habe ich angeschaut, Lucky Luke bin ich dabei, ich bin jetzt wieder, ich regrediere, ich bin wieder zurück in meiner Kindheit und ich bin full circle gegangen. Ich war gestern im Kino, weil ich bei der Premiere von einem fantastischen Film Our House war, den ihr unbedingt anschauen sollt. Aber die Stunde oder wie ist Schmerz? Our House im Sinne von A-U-E-R-H-A-U-S. Ach so, lange Geschichte. Guckt euch den Film an, da will ich es noch erklären. Jedenfalls war da vor mir jemand in der Schlange, und das Kino war halt voll für diese Premiere. Und vor mir war jemand in der Schlange, und ich war zu spät und musste da noch relativ schnell rein und so. Und hat mich geärgert über den Menschen vor mir, der sehr lange gebraucht hat. Und der wollte unbedingt, alleine war der, ich schätze mal so,
war zwischen 58 und 65 und wollte
unbedingt in die Eiskönigin zwei.
Und hat bezahlt bei einem
Hunderter und
hat so eine große Tasche dabei, wo ich auch nicht weiss,
also eine große Sporttasche.
Alles daran, wir fragen auf.
Und dann fand ich, ich wollte mich erst
aufregen über diesen Menschen, der vor mir die Reihe blockiert hat, auf der anderen Seite habe ich zu viele Fragen gehabt, über die ich mich gefreut habe, auch dann irgendwie, weil er so viele coole Rätsel aufgeworfen hat. Oder er ist einfach ein pädophiler Weirdo. Ja, der seine entführte Tochter einmal ins Kino bringen will. Ja, genau, richtig. Und in der großen Tasche, die gesuppelt hat die ganze Zeit. Er wollte in Frozen 2, er wollte ganz unbedingt wissen, ob es 3D ist, hat ein paar Mal gefreut, ob es 3D ist. Und war es 3D? War 3D und er konnte sich auch nicht vom Platz entscheiden, genau. War alles, war daran seltsam. Eigentlich müsstest du in dem Punkt sagen, okay, mein Tag wie jetzt ist es gelaufen, ich werde ab jetzt einfach diesem Mann folgen. Ja. Und einfach, vielleicht entsteht eine neue Serienidee oder sowas, ich werde diesem Mann einfach folgen und mir einfach angucken, wie der Tag so aussieht. Es gibt viele so Momente, wo man einfach sagen könnte sich jetzt entscheiden, einen anderen Abend zu haben, einen anderen Tag zu haben. Man geht dem dann immer nicht nach. Man ist dann zu seinen eigenen Routinen, seinen eigenen Grenzen gefangen. Man müsste eigentlich so wie im Fernsehen durchzappen können, so durch verschiedene Leute zappen können und denen zugucken. Kann man ja auf Twitch eigentlich. Ja, kann man eigentlich auf Twitch machen. So diese Real-Life-Streams, die ich immer extrem unangenehm finde.
Selbst Leute, die ich mag, die halt irgendwie dann einfach essen gehen mit Freunden, aber halt ihre Twitch-Kamera mitnehmen und halt live streamen.
Stellen die einen dann auch hin auf den leeren Platz?
Stellen die auch hin auf den Platz.
Also immer dabei. Bestellen die doch Essen?
Nee, so weit geht's nicht. Aber das ist dann schon, weil es ist komisch, weil man kann eine gewisse Performance nur eine gewisse Zeit lang aufrechterhalten. Also, oh cool, guckt ihr das Restaurant an, wir reden über coole Themen und man redet dann nicht über persönliche Themen, wie man es normalerweise machen würde mit Freunden. Man kann aber auch diesen Unterhaltungsmodus nicht lange aufrechterhalten, das heisst, irgendwann läuft es immer so ins Leere und dann sitzt man einfach nur da und isst und das ist ganz merkwürdig,
weil es ist so eine awkward silence,
obwohl man nur zuschaut. Das ist ganz, ganz merkwürdig.
Was ich ganz spannend finde, ist, wenn man
also angenommen so ein
Twitch-Chat steuert
diese Telepräsenz-Roboter, kennt man ja, diese
iPads auf Rädern und so.
Angenommen, die werden mal irgendwann
sehen ein bisschen besser aus,
macht mehr nach Mensch aus und so weiter und dann kann
ein Twitch-Chat, kann die steuern.
Heißt, der Twitch-Chat die ganze Zeit sagt, was er gerne machen würde gerade. Und dann ein cleverer Algorithmus fischt immer die Mehrheit heraus. Also meinetwegen sind hunderttausend Leute in diesem Chat und alle sagen, was sie gerne machen wollen würden jetzt gerade, was sie für Gedanken kommen und so weiter. und dann gibt es nämlich auch Befehle und dann gibt es einen Algorithmus, der wertet genau aus, was gerade die Mehrheit. Und immer die Mehrheit macht das. Wie würde sich dieser Roboter verhalten? Er würde sich sofort selbst zerstören. Ja? Ja, sofort. Er würde sofort in eine Straße laufen, an der Brücke springen. Ich glaube, das ist beruhigend. Aber stell dir mal vor, das Gruseligste wäre, wenn er sich benehmen würde wie ein Mensch. Aber das funktioniert nicht, weil der, aber angenommen, der Chat ist schneller und es ist nicht unbedingt Echtzeit, sondern wir speeden das mal ab. Schneller als Echtzeit? Wäre nicht Echtzeit, sondern wir müssen uns abspeeden. Wie gruselig es wäre, wenn dieser Roboter sich einfach verhalten würde wie ein normaler Mensch. Und ordentlich auffallen würde. Weil hunderttausend Menschen im Chat funktionieren wie dein Kopf und irgendwie gewinnt immer die Mehrheitsmeinung, weil es die gewachseneren Synapsenverbindungen sind oder sowas. Ist ja schon gruselig. Irgendwann verliert man den so in der Menschenmenge und irgendwann weiß niemand mehr, wer es ist, weil er überhaupt nicht auffällt. Und irgendwann merkt der Versuchsleiter, das war die ganze Zeit ich selbst. Und die Frage, an der man herausfinden kann, ob er in Europa der Säder nicht ist, wie Star Wars 8 fand. Weil da ist der Chat so gespalten, dass es ihm bringt. Das ist einfach zerbricht. Ja, das zerbricht. Aber es gab ja auch diesen einen Roboter oder dieses Gerät, dieser Hiking-Roboter, der einfach nur mitgenommen werden wollte. Und man wollte gucken, kann dieser Roboter von der East Coast in Amerika zur West Coast kommen, nur indem ihn Leute mitnehmen. Halt mit dem Auto ein Stück mitnehmen, dann setzt er ihn an der Strasse aus, dann wird er wieder eingeladen, wird mitgefahren. Innerhalb kürzester Zeit wurde er zerstört in irgendeiner Gosse. Vergewaltigt, zerstört, traumatisiert, ausgeraubt, zerstört. Naja, es ist schwierig. Ich glaube, es gab auch noch einen ganz tollen Artikel, den muss ich mal kurz finden, von einer Polizeimeldung in den USA, muss ich mal ganz kurz heraussuchen, wo es einen Police-Robot gibt neuerdings. Oh ja. Da gibt es da übrigens einen Police-Robot, bei dem man im Park, der fährt dann durch den Park, ist so ein grosses Ei. So sieht das aus. So grosses spaciges Man-in-Black-Wesen, so ein grosses Ei, was auf einem Staubsaugerroboter-Ding herumfährt, durch den Park und dann wurde eine Frau, wurde ausgeraubt und die wollte dann zu diesem Ding gehen und dann kannst du da draufdrücken und kannst einen Crime melden, aber der Roboter war defekt und hat die ganze Zeit gesagt,
Step out of the way, please, step out of the way.
Und dann, to add insult to injury, the high-tech device then rolled away while humming an intergalactic tune.
Der ist weggefahren, aber das ist so eine clickbaity-Seite so ein bisschen. Aber wie spezifisch?
While humming an intergalactic tune, pausing periodically to say, please keep the park clean. Das grosse Ei hat sich direkt dafür interessiert, dass die Frau gerade assortet wurde. Es hat eigenen Willen entwickelt, ja, es hat keinen Bock auf die Arbeit. Es hat nur die Arbeit. Ja, und es hat gesagt, please step out of the way, keep the park clean while humming an intergalactic tune.
Aber was ist ein intergalactic tune?
Ganz merkwürdig, ja.
Aber wie spezifisch das auch beschrieben ist in dem Artikel.
Aber man hat was im Kopf.
Ja, schon.
Kann man jetzt nicht abstreiten.
Aber der will einfach nur spazieren, gehen, summen und dass der Park sauber ist.
Das ist doch völlig verständlich.
Ich finde es grossartig.
Aber der akzeptiert auch, dass es ein bisschen assaulted wird und
Leute ausgehoben werden.
Gleich. Ja, ich glaube, irgendwie in
Abu Dhabi
oder irgendwie so in so einer
superreichen Stadt gab es auch so
einen Polizeiroboter, der ist dann in so einen Swimmingpool gefallen
und musste gerettet werden.
Von allen anderen Polizeirobotern,
die alle auch in den Swimmingpool gefallen sind.
Und einfach sämtliche Roboter der ganzen
Stadt fallen. Aber gut, dass man mittlerweile die
Vielen Dank. und musste gerettet werden. Von allen anderen Polizeirobotern, die alle auch in der Zwischenmöhe gefallen sind. Und einfach sämtliche Roboter der ganzen Stadt fallen. Aber gut, dass man mittlerweile die Dinge, die für Ordnung sorgen sollen, muss man retten. Und man hat deswegen keine Zeit für die wirklichen Probleme. Also die echten Polizisten müssen dann die Polizeiroboter. Er ist dieses Klassische, der Ball ist im Ast gefangen und man wirft einen anderen Ball, um ihn rauszuholen, der bleibt auch drin. Und irgendwann ist das gesamte Hab und. Ja, manche ich mir, was ist Baum, was ist Ball? Ja, die Scooby-Doo-Decke, alles hängt im Baum und irgendwann muss man zur Feuerwehr gehen und sagen, ja, pass auf Freunde. Alles, alles hängt im Baum, ich habe nichts mehr. Ich weiß nicht, wo ich nicht schlafen soll, Haus im Baum. Vielleicht haben so Baumhäuser angefangen, dass einfach Leute angefangen haben, ihr ganzes Haus in den Baum zu werfen, dass irgendwann drin hängen. Irgendwann war nichts über. Jetzt müssen wir umziehen. Hattest du mal ein Baumhaus, ein schönes Baumhaus? Ich habe häufiger so Häuser im Wald gebaut, aber auf dem Boden, nicht im Baum. Aber es ist immer die langweiligere Weise, noch den Boden zu bauen. Das heißt, du bist schon in Kompromisse eingegangen. Ich hatte ja einen eigenen Raum für mich, und zwar über der Garage. Die Garage ist ja ein grosser Quader, aber das Dach ist spitz. Und da gibt es dann so einen dreieckigen Raum, und der war einfach frei. Ich weiß nicht, wofür der gedacht war, aber da war ich drin, und da war einfach gar nichts. Und da hatte ich dann so eine Art kleines gebautes Baumhaus für mich. Da war dann so ein Tisch drin und meine Comics, Simpsons Comics, und ich hatte eine Schreibmaschine, weil ich mir dachte, was braucht man da, eine Schreibmaschine, klar. Und da haben auch ein paar ab und zu Freunde übernachtet, das war sehr schön. Wäre du in deinem Bett geschlafen hast. Das war das näheste an einem Baumhaus, wo ich je war. Das ist kein Baumhaus. Es ist kein Baumhaus, aber es ist besser als nichts. Es war auf jeden Fall eine gute Zeit. Keine weiteren Fragen, meine liebe Jury. Ich habe auch mal mit einem Freund übernachtet und hatte dann so viel Angst, dass ich nachts nach Hause gegangen bin. Moment, ganz kurz. Du hast so viel Angst, dass du das Haus, das sichere Haus verlassen hast, um die grosse Allee an Friedhofer lang zu gehen, nach Hause. Ja, nee, ich hatte, ich glaube, ich bin irgendwann aufgewacht und habe dann an die Tür des Bruders von meinem Freund geklopft, der älter war, und habe denen gesagt, ich will nach Hause, weil mein
Teddybär ist traurig. Mein Teddybär hat Heimweh, der will nach Hause.
Wie alt war der Bruder?
Zwei Jahre älter, keine Ahnung, er war dann zehn oder so.
Der ältere Bruder war zehn Jahre alt und dann hatte ich nach Hause gefahren.
Auf seinem Fahrrad.
Mein Motorrad, ja.
Der Freund und ich haben in derselben Siedlung gewohnt, das war nur ein paar hundert Meter entfernt.
Hundert Meter vielleicht entfernt.
Aber gut, dass es sich an den zehnjährigen wendet.
Ja, natürlich, das war erwachsen.
Da merkt man damals sein Verantwortungsbewusstsein. Jetzt muss man sich an jemanden wenden, der das Problem lösen kann. Weil ich meine, Teddy sind hier sichtlich überfordert. Und der Freund ist zusammen mit mir eingeschlafen und am nächsten Tag war ich weg. Und er hat dann durchaus zu Recht gefragt, wo warst du? Ich bin... Bisschen wie so ein One-Night-Stand, wo man morgens weg, abhaut. Wir sind zusammen ins Bett gegangen in verschiedene Betten natürlich, hat er sich ... Aber da habe ich auch gesagt, ja, du kennst es ja. Hat für mich nicht gepasst. Manchmal ist der Teddy traurig und dann muss man halt machen, was der Teddy ... Aber auch sehr verständnisvoll dann, ja klar. Klar, nee. Wenn meine kleine Kuh traurig ist, dann ... Warum kann man das heute nicht mehr machen, dass man einfach sagt, oh, Party ist morgen, oh, meinem Mammut geht's heute nicht gut gut, meinem kleinen Stoffmammut. Das klingt doch wie ein Euphemismus. Ja, das stimmt schon. Irgendwie, keine Ahnung, der hat Stress. Ich muss mich um den kümmern heute. Kinder sind gut, aber du kannst nicht zu oft behaupten, du hättest ein Kind, wenn du kein Kind hast. Irgendwann fällt das auf. Ja, viele Fragen wirft man dann von allem auf. Das ist so wie die imaginäre Freundin, die man hat, die auch irgendwann auffliegt, wo man so eine komplette Geschichte sich ausdenken muss. Wie? Die fliegen auf. Wie imaginäre Freundinnen fliegen auf. Naja, weil du musst ja die Geschichte immer weiter treiben und dann, wie heißt die, wie könnte sowas aufliegen? Wie geht die zur Schule? Wie geht die zur Schule? Naja, du musst ja Fragen beantworten irgendwann und dann so, ja, wie ihr seid zusammen, aber ihr habt euch seit Monaten nicht gesehen. Ja, sag mal so ein paar Dinge, die einen verraten würden. Naja, zum Beispiel sowas, dass sie nie jemand gesehen hat, dass es keine Fotos von ihr gibt, dass die Fotos, die man weitergibt, durch die Google-Rückwärtssuche auf ein polnisches Model zurückzuführen sind, die auch einfach zehn Jahre älter ist als man selbst. So, das sind so ein paar Punkte, wo man einfach merken kann, dass es da irgendwie komisch zugeht, wenn sich der Name ab und zu ändert, irgendwie die Aussprache. Sag noch fünf weitere Punkte. Okay, wenn man zum Beispiel nicht genau weiß, was die Eltern für Berufe haben oder irgendwie so was, der Nachname stimmt nicht genau, wo hat man sich überhaupt... Man widerspricht sich auch mit dem Nachnamen. Wo hat man sich das erste Mal getroffen und so. Das muss halt alles stimmen. Döner. Genau, und dann ist halt so das Problem, wenn halt dann irgendwie die Nina aus der Parallelklasse sagt, wollen wir ausgehen, dann muss man einen Grund haben, warum man dann gerade die Freundin nicht mehr hat. So, das ist dann schon schwierig. Stimmt. Also imaginäre Freundin
und echte Freundin geht nicht zusammen.
Ist schwierig, ist auf jeden Fall schwierig.
Es ist eine Herausforderung. Ich glaube, es geht.
Manche können das. Offene Beziehung und imaginäre Freundin?
Ja, kann sein.
Das ist eigentlich auch schön.
Eine Beziehung ist so, ja, irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, engt mich diese Beziehung ein.
Ich würde schon gerne noch eine imaginäre Freundin
dazuhaben.
Warum? Also was? Ja, die in Kanada lebt und irgendwie so eine, keine Ahnung, die Schatzsucherin ist und irgendwie so Gold sucht im Fluss. Sorry, ich muss mit dir Schluss machen. Warum? Mein Teddy ist traurig und der muss jetzt ins Bett. Und deswegen musst du Schluss machen? Ja. Sorry, ciao. Ich glaube, kurz bei deinem acht Jahre alten Bruder, um mich nach Hause fliegen zu lassen. Aber ich glaube, es gibt manche, gibt es da nicht irgendwie so Geschichten von irgendeinem Mann, der im Krankenhaus ist und dann kommen plötzlich acht Freundinnen, um ihn zu besuchen und alle wissen nichts voneinander? Ich habe das eigentlich immer für Quatsch gehalten, habe das aber selber mal erlebt, und zwar eine ganz abstruse Geschichte. Ich habe in meiner Jugendjahre an so einem Bauerntheater gearbeitet, im Nachbarort irgendwie, weil ich wollte Schauspieler werden und das war das Einzige, was es gab in der Nähe. Und dann habe ich da auch so Workshops gemacht und irgendwann war ich dann, habe ich mir ein bisschen Geld verdient und war da Regieassistent und habe die Technik gemacht.
Und dann war da eben auch der Hauptdarsteller und der hat sich für die Premiere, also Premiere, er war der Hauptdarsteller, so du weisst, du musst was aus dem Abend machen.
Das ist vielleicht der Höhepunkt deines Fames, der Höhepunkt deines hohen Ansehens, Hauptdarsteller Premiere.
Und dann hat er sich für diesen Abend drei Dates organisiert.
Drei separate Dates, die nichts voneinander wussten.
Und er hat dann davor schon so gemeint, das wird schwierig und so.
Und ich meinte, ja, okay, wie hast du dir das denn vorgestellt?
Weil, also ist es, und er meinte dann so, ja, nee, das passt schon, weil die sind alle halt eine Stunde versetzt. Also du hast ein Date für 18 Uhr, eins für 19 Uhr, eins für 20 Uhr. Aber die Premiere, aber alle haben das geschaut. Halt die nebeneinander gesetzt, oder das ist auf viele Fragen. Das ist so die Frage, das sind vier Fragen. Und man meinte halt so, ja, und dann so, ja, keine Ahnung, wir treffen uns nach der Premiere. Und ich glaube, er hat verschiedene Daten. Er meinte nur, es sind eine Stunde Abstand, wo ich mir dachte, was passiert in dieser einen Stunde, weil ist es dann, wenn das erste Date schlecht läuft, sagst du dann, hau ab, nimmst die nächste. Also noch eine Stunde muss man auf die neue warten, auch lang. Was ist, wenn das erste Date gut läuft, schickt man die dann auch weg und dann, ich weiß es nicht, und dieser Abend war Chaos, war reines Chaos und am Ende saßen alle drei am Tisch mit allen Schauspielern und mir und es war eine ganz unangenehme Stimmung, weil die natürlich sehr schnell gecheckt haben, was los ist und weil dann hast du halt immer dieses Vorstellenproblem, dieses ah, das ist Miriam und das ist Agatha. Jetzt würde man normalerweise sagen, was die Verbindung ist, aber das lasse ich aus. Kann ich jetzt nicht. Ganz, ganz merkwürdig und ich dachte mir schon damals, wow. Und dann haben die drei, also die haben es schnell gecheckt und haben Schauspieler dann so ein Jackpot-Gefühl, weil. Ich glaube nicht, die hatten einen sehr unangenehmen Abend und er hatte viel zu erklären und es
ist, glaube ich, nichts geworden. Aber ich verstehe
schon den Impuls zu sagen, ich habe diesen
einen Abend, da sehe ich gut aus.
Ich muss wirklich das Beste daraus
machen, so wenn man einfach alles
auf ein, wenn man ganz viel Geld hat
und dann das
investieren muss in drei verschiedene Sachen, ergeben nicht so viel
Sinn, aber du verstehst, was ich mache.
Wenn du weißt, du hast heute Abend richtig Glück, dann sagst du, okay, ich gehe ins Casino, ich spiele Lotto und schaue in Gully rein und gucke einfach mal, was ich finde. Ich gucke mal, was passiert. Ich schaue einfach mal, was passiert. Eines muss man sich immer offen lassen. Das stimmt schon. Eine ganz furchtbare Geschichte von einem Kollegen, ein Bekannter, der hatte eine Familie, wo der, ich weiß nicht mehr genau zusammen, jedenfalls hat, ich glaube es ist noch ein fernter, es gibt nur einen Mann, den Vater und der Vater hat irgendwann irgendwann seine Frau verloren. Wie verloren? Die ist gestorben an der Krankheit, glaube ich. Und der hatte auch keine Kinder, nur diese Frau. Die ist gestorben, die lag im Sterben, genau so was, die lag im Sterben und dann ist er abgehauen um Punkt 18 Uhr, weil er jeden Abend um Punkt 18 Uhr abgehauen ist. Und dann kam nachher raus, der ist zu seiner Zweitfamilie gefahren, weil er die ganze Zeit eine zweite Familie hatte, die bis zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht aufgeflogen ist. Und die wusste von seiner anderen Ehe. Und mit denen hat er auch Kinder gehabt und so weiter. Aber die erste Ehe wusste nichts von der zweiten. Ne, genau, die Ehefrau, die dann gestorben ist, und wahrscheinlich war der einfach unglaublich erleichter, dass diese Frau irgendwann gestorben ist. Natürlich. Was als furchtbares ... Oder er braucht genau diesen Nervenkitzel. Die Frage ist, ob da noch ein Dritter dazugekommen ist, ob er das braucht, sozusagen, dieses Hin und Her. Das fand ich so uner. Trotzdem hat die, glaube ich, nicht mehr mehr bis zum Ende, weil das war halt so sein, er ist immer getrennt. Und dann um 18 Uhr geht es dann ab zur anderen Familie. Krass. Oh, das ist eine ganze Zeit. Das ist schon weird. Und dann hat die erste Familie nie gefragt, was genau passiert um 18 Uhr? Nee, es war immer so, und man kennt das ja auch, Familien haben ja so komische Rituale. Also es ist alles sehr tradition jede Woche ist irgendwie gleich, vielleicht du nicht an deine Kinder erinnerst, das war schon immer alles sehr durchgetaktet so, montags waren immer gleich, bei uns war immer irgendwie, war alles schon durchgetaktet. Ich kann mir schon vorstellen, wenn man nichts anderes kennt und der Vater ist halt immer ab 18 Uhr weg, weil er halt abends arbeiten muss, Nachtschicht oder whatever, dann kann man das schon hinkriegen. Ist ja ganz perfide. Ja, aber ist auch ganz gut, dass man nicht immer alles erklären muss, finde ich, so, dass man einfach sagt, so, ich gehe jetzt, ohne zu sagen, wohin man geht, so einfach, weil so man geht halt. Du bist jemand, der sich nicht gerne erklärt, ne, der sich nicht gerne erklärt. Ne, ich bin Mysterium. Genau, bist du in der großen Mysterybox. Ich frage dich ja immer, was du machst. Aber du sagst ja dann nie, was du genau gemacht hast. Was machst du denn sonst so? Ich bin unterwegs. Ich schaue in Gullis, jeden Gullideckel. Irgendwas kann da sein, irgendwas ist da doch, irgendwas lauert da. Es gibt eine ganze Welt unter uns, irgendwas muss da sein.
Ja, Ratten, glaube ich, primär. Aber welche Ratten, wie groß sind die, wo sind die? Da kratzt es doch immer unter der Erde. Was ist da? Was passiert da? Dieser Dampf kommt da raus, wo kommt der her? Wer macht diesen Damm?
Was ist ein Erdbeben? Wer macht da Rambazamba? Was ist da los?
Das sind die Fragen, die ich mir stelle. Jede Nacht schaue ich in den Gullideckel und denke mir, ich glaube, du hast zu viel Zeit. Hallo, hallo, hallo. Was ist das? Was ist da? Schlange, du hast ein gutes Schlangengeräusch nachgemacht. Ja, man kann sich genau vorstellen, wie die Schlange im Jenseits verschwinden. Aber wie sieht es so aus, hast du zu viel Zeit oder warum guckst du gerne in den Gullydeckel rein? Oder ist es die neue Phase? Ja, ich denke mir halt, so irgendjemand muss es rausfinden. Irgendjemand muss es rausfinden und wenn ich es bin, dann habe ich auf jeden Fall mal einen Punkt. Habe ich mal einen Punkt geholt. In Affektion schon sehr beliebt, das Stilmittel des Untergrundes. So in S zum Beispiel, der Clown, der auch im Gullydeckel gewohnt hat. Ja, ja klar. Vier böse Dinge kommen aus dem Untergrund heraus. Der Keller natürlich, Psycho auch im Keller, die Mutter ist im Keller, wird dann aber nach oben gebracht. Ins Über-Ich. Ja, ganz interessant. Ganz interessant, guter Film auch. Werbung Nee, ist mir zu kompliziert. Aber es ist doch total einfach, ein Girokonto aufzumachen, zum Beispiel bei der Commerzbank. Was? Du gehst einfach auf ufo.commerzbank.de und kannst in wenigen Minuten dein eigenes Girokonto aufmachen.
Jetzt hört es aber hier noch nicht auf. Es geht noch weiter.
Echt?
Du kriegst auch noch 20.000 Euro geschenkt.
Nee, 100 Euro geschenkt, aber es ist auch schon mal was.
Das ist ein Anfang.
Das ist ein Anfang. Und wenn du dann noch Familie oder Verwandte oder sonstige wildfremde Menschen wirbst, auch ein Konto aufzumachen, kriegst du weitere 100 Euro.
Das ist nicht ja ernst.
Aber keine Kreditkarte.
Keine, ja gut, dann...
Natürlich kriegst du eine Kreditkarte oben drauf, ist doch kein Problem.
Alles muss raus, heute ohne schöne Lachseite kriegst du auch noch oben drauf, kein Problem.
Wo geht doch mal drauf, welche E-Mail in der Reise?
So, lässt du mich antworten?
Auf welche Seite gehe ich nochmal?
ufo.commerzbank.de Und nun weiterhin viel Spaß mit der Folge. Werbung. Guckst du gerne Schwarz-Weiss-Filme oder du hast mal gesagt, du kannst sie zu nicht aufraffen. Nee, ich kann nicht nicht haben. Ich weiß nicht, ich habe da zu viele Sperren im Kopf, auch für meinen eigenen, ich hätte sie gerne nicht, aber ich habe sie trotzdem, kann man nicht mal nichts machen. Ich schaue dann doch lieber nochmal Tim und Struppi an. So, das ist für mich dann einfach nochmal der Film. Ja, diese Netflix-Kids-Phase. Ja, es ist eine ganz merkwürdige Phase, ich bin da tief drin, aber du findest im normalen Netflix einfach keinen vernünftigen Content. Alles klar. Alles ist Crap, alles hat man schon mal gesehen. Es ist einfach, ich weiß auch nicht wohin. Es ist schwierig. Welche Stream-Plattformen kannst du dennfehlen? Ach, also, pfff, da könnte ich dir jetzt einige nennen. Könnte ich dir jetzt wirklich einige, eine, eine, eine besonders nennen. Aber ja, nee, ich glaube da unten, da findet noch einige statt. Da ist viel los. Ich glaube auch, da ist viel los. Ich habe mich letztens wieder ein bisschen mit Verschwörungstheorien beschäftigt. Leider sehr viel Zeit verschwendet, muss man leider sagen. Das ist halt immer das Problem. Das ist ein Rabbit Hole. Es gibt ja die eine Verschwörungstheorie, der Mud Flood, dass es irgendwann mal eine grosse Schlammflut gab, dass einfach ganz viel Schlamm kam. Woher? Weiß man nicht. Ganz viel Schlamm. Und als Beweis werden diese Kellerfenster angeführt. Diese Fenster, diese halbgrossen Fenster, die so am, also so Kellerschächte, so kleine Fenster. Und das Argument ist, das ja geht ja nicht, sondern das muss eigentlich ein normales Fenster sein, das aber zur Hälfte mit Schlamm bedeckt ist. Und dann hat man die Tür einfach höher gebaut und die Häuser weiter benutzt, aber halt mit einer höheren Tür. Ist das nicht sehr einfach zu widerlegen? Ja, klar. Aber es hält sich trotzdem. Und es ist einfach verrückt. Das ist spannend. Es gibt Leute, aber das ist so eine Theorie, die ist auch egal. Es gibt ja Verschwörungstheorien, die sind so ein bisschen problematisch, aber andere, die sind auch einfach egal. Da gibt es dann auch eine Verschwörungstheorie, dass irgendein Berg irgendwo in der Wüste, der halt so aussieht wie ein Baumstumpf. Vielleicht kennt man diese Berge, diese Plateauberge, die oben ganz glatt sind und dann halt so hochführen. Und die sagen halt, es war mal ein riesiger Baum, der gefällt wurde und dann ist der Baumstumpf versteinert. So eine riesige Theorie. Die Frage ist natürlich, wo ist der Baum? Kann man nicht, kann die nicht beantworten, aber es ist trotzdem eine Theorie. Und das sind dann so Sachen, die ich der ganze Tastante finde.
Genau, wir hatten es ja auch schon mal damit, aber ich finde es ja immer spannend, wenn, unverständlich, wenn man Verschwörungstheorien hat, wo man dann selber plötzlich so einer elitären Gruppe angehört, die alles durchschaut hat, der erlesene Kreis, und man macht sich selbst zum Helden und zu einem besseren Menschen. Ich weiss, die Maulwurfmenschen leben unter uns.
Genau. Bei so einer Theorie mit dem Baum oder auch mit dem Schlamm, was bringt es dir daran zu glauben? Weil selbst wenn es so wäre, bei allen wäre es so ein... Du machst dich ja dadurch nicht zu einem besseren Menschen, weil du Baum suchst. Aber du bist halt immer so auf dieser Vertuschung, die Medien vertuschen das mit der Mudflat. Und auch die Frage, warum? Ich glaube, es ist so... Warum sollte man das so durch?
Aber jetzt ist mir klar geworden, Mudflood ist einfach saukool.
Es ist ein geiles Wort.
9-11 was an inside job.
Meine Güte.
Wohingegen, Mudflood?
Flat Earth.
Es funktioniert einfach richtig.
Flat Earth, Mudflood.
Es klingt einfach gut.
Ich glaube, ich nehme mein erstes, zweites und drittes Kind Mudflood. Mudfloat. Mudflat. Eins, Mudflat eins. Mudflat will, finde ich gut. Ja, aber ich hatte jetzt tatsächlich auch ein bisschen Kontakt mit dem Phänomen der Holocaust-Leugnung. Ganz kritisches Thema, ganz schwierig, aber kann man auch nicht viel machen. Ja, kannst du nicht gegen das machen. Kann man nicht viel gegen machen. Ja, haben wir schon mal empfohlen, The Devil Next Door, auf Netflix anschauen, fantastische Doku, die man so mitbekommen hat sogar. Ich erinnere mich noch ein bisschen an diesen Demjanjuk-Fall, weil er ja 2009 oder so erst in Deutschland dann verurteilt wurde. Das ist dieser angebliche KZ-Wächter, der dann verurteilt werden sollte in Israel. Genau, und dann dann wurde er doch in München, glaube ich, verurteilt, hier in Deutschland. Aber er war schon 92 oder sehr alt jedenfalls. Ich erinnere mich noch an diese Diskussion, was bringt es denn noch, so einen 92-Jährigen ins Gefängnis zu sperren, das ist doch Quatsch. An diese Diskussion erinnere ich mich noch. Jetzt war man ja auch nicht so alt, war ein paar Jahre her, sieben Jahre her, acht, neun, wie viele Jahre haben wir, zehn Jahre schon her. Wo ist man auf der Gefängnishierarchie? Weil es gibt ja auch im Gefängnis so eine Hierarchie, an welche Straftaten, die, die schlimm, also selbst in einem Gefängniskontext, wo ja alle, sag ich mal, Dreck am Stecken haben, selbst da noch bestraft werden. Also klassisch natürlich der Kinderschänder, der selbst im Gefängnis noch einen sehr schweren Stand hat. Wo ist man als... Weil es da keine Kinder gibt. Also... Es ist schwierig. Es ist schwierig. Wo ist der KZ-Wächter? Sagt man da... Hut ab oder... Vor allem ist... Wie ist da die Beziehung zu den Wächtern im Gefängnis? Man weiß es nicht genau. Man weiß es nicht genau. Nee, man weiss so wenig. Man weiss fast nichts darüber.
Ja, vor allem der hat ja so einen Deathcount von 400.000 oder sowas.
Da kriegst du auch irgendwann eine Einzelzelle verdient.
Ja.
Weiss ich nicht.
Das stimmt schon.
Schwieriges Thema.
Schwierig, aber das kann man auf jeden Fall empfehlen.
Das ist sehr spannend.
Und mir geht es bei solchen Dokus auch immer so, ich bin entweder 100% von der Unschuld überzeugt oder 100% von der Schuld überzeugt. Ich habe nichts dazwischen, nie. Ich denke mir nie, ja, da müssen wir jetzt mal beide Seiten vernünftig an. Ich bin immer 100% auf einer Seite. Und ich bin mir sicher, so geht es den meisten auch. Und welchen besseren Beweis gibt es dafür, dass Dürresysteme bescheuert sind, als man selbst vor True-Crime-Dokus, wo man die ganze Zeit hundert Prozent von einer Wahrheit überzeugt ist, von der man keine Ahnung hat. Und man ist sofort wieder vom Gegenteil überzeugt, wenn der Gegenanwalt plötzlich was anderes auskramt. Ist wie ein Pendel. Nee, nicht wie ein Pendel. Wie ein Pendel, wo der Mittelteil nicht existiert. So bin ich dann bei so Todokus. Bist du da reflektierter? Ich bin da nicht reflektiert.
Ja, bei mir ist es, ich bin eigentlich, ich bin dann eher das Pendel, ja genau, ich bin dann auf einer Seite und dann total auf der anderen Seite und bei dem Fall ist es natürlich besonders dramatisch, weil da geht es um Todesstrafe und dann ist so, dann wird er zur Todesstrafe verurteilt, Spoiler, und dann kommen halt nochmal neue Informationen ans. Und das ist halt ultra unangenehm, weil man denkt so, wir können den jetzt, welche Informationen muss man dann noch zulassen? Weil du kannst ja immer sagen, ah, ich habe hier noch neue Dokumente gefunden und die müssen wir jetzt erst gerichtlich prüfen. Das kann man ja immer machen, man käme ja nie zu einer Verstreckung einer Todesstrafe, weil der Anwalt ja immer sagen kann, hier in diesem Archiv, hier ist noch eine Kiste, lass uns die noch mal angucken, weil dann muss man noch mal vor Gericht das alles angucken mit Sachverständigen, bla bla bla. Es hört ja nie auf, irgendwann, wenn man dieses System hat, muss man ja sagen, ab jetzt ist es und das ist halt ultra unangenehm. Deswegen denke ich mir immer nur so, zum Glück gibt es keine Todesstrafe in Deutschland, weil es einfach ein furchtbares System ist, weil man irgendwie sonst immer sagen kann, ja, sorry, war falsch, komm raus. Aber Jury-System ist natürlich offensichtlich Quatsch. Es gibt viele solche Sachen, die offensichtlich Quatsch sind. Gibt es irgendjemand, der sagt, Jury-System ist eine gute Idee? Nee. Und aber trotzdem macht man es noch. Ich glaube, wurde nicht auch irgendwie, naja, schwierig. Weil Jury sind halt auch einfach normale, schlechte Menschen. Ja, und dann auch bei anderen Tukram-Luku-Staircase auch sehr, sehr zu empfehlen, sehr spaßig, das gleiche, also es ist auch immer, oh Jesus Christ, dazu, du kannst mit den Armen nehmen. Aha, immer wenn ich mir zu einem wichtigen Punkt mich nach vorne lehne, rutscht mein Ellenbogen ab, weil ich vollidiot bin und jegliche Autorität ist sofort untergraben. Ich weiß nicht, wie du dazu stehst, aber ich finde es schwierig, dass man mit dem Holocaust in dieser Serie ist der Holocaust immer wieder ein Cliffhanger. Er wird für so einen emotionalen Cliffhanger benutzt, was ich schwierig finde, weil diese Doku ist ja dramaturgisch aufgebaut, dass man spielt die ganze Zeit mit Informationen und man spielt die ganze Zeit mit der Neugierde, hat er diese ganzen Juden umgebracht oder nicht und eigentlich ist es doch der falsche Umgang, genau wie Michael Hanecke ja auch immer das Liste in einem Interview wahnsinnig fertig gemacht hat, weil er sagt, du kannst du nicht mit dem Holocaust umgehen, mit sowas Schrecklichem, du kannst es nicht so dir zurechtbiegen, wie du es für deine Geschichte brauchst, das ist kein Stoff für Lighthearted Fiction und so und genauso snackt man ja auch diese Dokus weg. Die wenigsten Schinders Liste als Light, Hard and Fiction bezeichnet würden. Naja, Mainstreamer Blockbuster, das meine ich damit.
War es nicht sogar so, dass bei Schinders Liste Popcorn verboten wurde?
Ja.
In manchen vielen Kinosiste Popcorn verboten wurde?
Ja?
Ja.
Ich glaube, in vielen Kinos wurde Popcorn verboten, was auch so ist, das ist dann das Zeichen des Respekts, dass man kein Popcorn ist.
Popcorn und Juden.
Ja, das ist so.
Du hast weiterhin Schokolinsen essen, Nachos sind okay, aber kein Popcorn, ne, aus Respekt. Ja, genau, aber ich finde es schwierig, Ehrlich gesagt, habe ich da noch selber keine Antwort für mich gefunden. Was natürlich zum einen dafür gut ist, um Leuten überhaupt das mal nahezubringen, was da so los war. Und so, gerade Leuten, die nicht interessiert sind, geschichtsinteressiert sind, aber halt True Crime interessiert, was ja mittlerweile jeder ist auf eine Art, weil es ja wahnsinnig populär ist. Auf der anderen Seite spielt man aber die ganze Zeit damit, als wäre es irgendwie so ein Stilmittel, um Cliffhanger zu erzeugen und die nächste Folge anzugucken. Weiß ich noch nicht genau. Wie heissen diese True Crime-Serie mit Marc Benecke, wo der immer Luminol erklärt die ganze Zeit? Da gibt es doch irgendwie so eine... Das klingt aber wahrlich spannend, wenn die ganze Zeit Luminol erklärt. Ja, ich glaube, da braucht es mal so einen Best-of-Zusammenschnitt. Marc Benecke erklärt Luminol, das ist dieses Zeug, was Blut leuchten lässt. Das sieht dann ganz cool aus. Und das ist halt. Und das ist halt, in jedem zweiten Fall wird das halt gebraucht. Und Marc Benecke erklärt jedes Mal aufs Neue, immer geduldig, immer aufs Neue. Das spürt man da drauf und dann leuchtet es. Hat man immer gesagt, dass man einfach einen Clip einsenden kann das letzte Mal? Nee, es ist immer ein anderer Clip. Mach diesen Zusammenschnitt einfach. Erzählt das immer anders? Wie heißt der denn Criminal Minds, Criminal Cases, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung? Es ist eigentlich eine amerikanische Serie, die übersetzt wird, aber oft werden Experten ersetzt durch deutschsprachige Experten wie Mark Benekwit, der dann nochmal zum monatsten Mal erklärt. Und auch so der Typ ist halt Doktor, kennt sich super aus, hat Hitler sitziert und irgendwie. Und wenn er beim dritten Mal sitzt, nochmal. Ja, und jemand, der die Serie das erste Mal sieht, denkt sich, warum ist der so schlecht drauf? Warum ist der so genervt? Oh Gott, Leute, Luminol. Zum letzten Mal. Ich sag's jetzt noch ein einziges Mal. Fucking Luminol bringt Blut. Nee, und dann gab's ja diesen großen Staircase-Fall, der eine komplette Netflix-Serie ist. Genau. Mit vielen Teilen, mit Superspannung, mit hin und her, wer war's. Und in dieser True-Crime-Serie ist es ein Einfall, 30 Minuten und er wird komplett geklärt und sagt, ja, so war's und so, nicht anders.
Das finde ich so geil, dass einerseits eine Theorie aus dieser Serie so übernehmen kann, dass es für die überhaupt keine Frage ist, und die Serie macht es als großes Mysterium auf, und Mark Benicke sagt, ja, es war so und so, ciao. Wirklich, ja, zu welchem Ergebnis kommt der? Das weiss ich ehrlich gesagt nicht. Ich bin nicht so der True Crime, ich bin da nicht so drin, aber ich finde es lustig, wie einerseits so aufgewählt, aber Marc Benicke macht das. Marc Benicke meines einfach, wie Luminol funktioniert, das ist einfach klar. Ja, es sind so manche Berufe, wo man ein Wissen braucht und das klingt wahnsinnig komplex und so, aber vielleicht hast du dann einfach, dein Beruf klingt so unantastbar, aber eigentlich hast du nur Luminol verstanden. Ja, ich glaube auch so Arzt ist einfach, du hast halt dieses Piepding verstanden. Du weißt, piep, piep, oh, oh, oh, da ist ein Problem und piep, piep, passt, perfekt, passt. Ja, das ist so. Da haben wir so Erfahrungswerte, was passiert, um es zu beschleunigen und so weiter. Da habe ich auch mal einen Podcast darüber gehört, dass das anscheinend Leute eher noch kranker macht, diese Krankenhausatmosphäre, auch mit diesen ganzen Geräten, die oft nicht harmonisch, sondern disharmonisch und auch in einem komischen Rhythmus die ganze Zeit miteinander piepen. Und irgendjemand hat sich zur Aufgabe gemacht, sozusagen die Krankenhausumgebung jetzt als musikalisches Problem zu betrachten oder als Klangproblem zu betrachten und einfach zu sagen, lass uns die Geräte irgendwie harmonische Akkorde bilden lassen oder so, wenn die eh schon zusammen piepen die ganze Zeit oder die in den Rhythmus bringen, so dass du jetzt halt im Krankenhaus liegst und du halt die ganze Zeit so piepen, piep, piep, piep, piep, piep, piep, piep und nein! Und wein! Die ganze Zeit! Reggaeton! Reggaeton! Ja, Gott. Und die einfach die ganze Zeit so coole, sphärische Musik spielen, anstatt Beep, Beep, wo du einfach wahnsinnig wirst in einer Zeit. Du bist eh schon krank, diese geht schon schlecht. Arturale Musik ist ja nichts anderes, oder komplexe Musik ist ja nichts anderes als schwer zu lösende Formeln für den Kopf. Weil die Wellenlängen ja nichts anderes sind als die immer alle Zusammenhänge. Spannend, weiter. Wellenlängen haben immer Zusammenhänge und die einfache Akkorde, die C-Dur, da haben die Wellenlängen der verschiedenen Töne, dieser drei Töne, sind einfach zu lösen. Die sind dann im Verhältnis von zwei zu drei. Das macht es im Kopf. Die macht es im Kopf. Das macht der Kopf im Kopf. Check es sofort. Da brauchst du kein Papier. Nee, brauchst nicht darüber nachdenken. Das Das ist so, ich glaube, so eine Quinte ist ein Verhältnis von zwei zu drei, die Wellenlängen.
Die haben viele gemeinsame Nenner so, das ist okay. Schwieriger wird es dann bei so Siebenakkorden und irgendwann Wagners Tristan-Akkord und so weiter. Oh mein Gott. Weil wir sind immer sehr komplex und deswegen glaube ich ja, dass Leute, die viel Musik hören, irgendwann dazu neigen, komplexere Musik zu hören, weil irgendwann das Gehirn used ist, diese Formeln zu lösen im Kopf. Wie jemand, der sich sehr viel mit Mathematik auseinandersetzt, auch irgendwann in der Lage ist, komplexere Formeln zu lösen. Schon wieder fünf plus vier. Longweilig! Keine Lust mehr. Gebt mir mal was Großes. Schon wieder Luminol. Auch an der Kasse, auch an der Kasse.
Mei, gib mir mal eine Wurzel hier!
Nicht immer nur 4,60 plus 8,20, Logarithmus, komm schon, gib mir mal was!
Ja genau, und dann glaube ich, so funktioniert auch Musik.
Und deswegen kann ich es verstehen, weil ich glaube, wenn diese ganzen Geräte ja irgendeinen Ton haben, dann ist es glaube ich einfach nur wahnsinnig nervig und strapazierend.
Es ist ja auch so, bei Elektrozügen, ich glaube die meisten Züge, dass die ja, die haben ja keine Gangschaltung, aber die müssen ja trotzdem irgendwie anfahren und dadurch haben die ja immer so diese Frequenzen, wo sie so einen Sprung machen und da hat man sich ja anscheinend darauf geeinigt, dass man eine Tonleiter macht, weil es ist ja auch willkürlich. Aber welche? Moll?
Weg ist er. Weg. Aber finde ich gut. Man könnte, glaube ich, viele Dinge auch so, wie so eine Fahrradklingel klingt, dass sich das alles abstimmt. So dass man alle Hupen und Fahrradklingeln miteinander abstimmt, dass es schöne Klänge zusammen ergibt, dass die ganze Welt mehr in Harmonie ist. Jetzt hat man ja in den USA die Notarzt-Sounds so randomisiert. Die ist ja nicht mehr so, sondern es ist ja ab und zu dieses, also es ist so random, verstehst du? Ja, damit man sich nicht nicht ... Es hat dann dieses Rattern zwischendurch.
Ja, aber ist da nicht ein DJ mit im Beifahrersitz?
Ja. Ich dachte, da ist immer einer ...
Guck gelaunter, ausser beim Todesfall, er ist nicht so gut gelaunt.
Traurig, Hand an Kopfhörer, traurig.
Ja, ja, ja.
Aber das ist ja, glaube ich, auch in New York so, dass man sich nicht an die Sirenen gewöhnt und dann irgendwann sieht, Wicke, wicke, wicke, wicke, wicke, wicke, wicke, wicke, wicke, wicke, wicke, wicke.
Aber das ist ja, glaube ich, auch in New York so, dass man sich nicht an die Sirenen gewöhnt und dann irgendwann sie nicht mehr hört.
Deswegen kann man sich nicht mehr daran gewöhnen, deswegen haben die die jetzt willkürlich gemacht.
Genau. Ja, wo ich aber bei The Staircase noch hinaus wollte, da ist halt das Spannende, diese Serie, die langatmige Serie, da sieht man ja irgendwann die Jury, wie die den Garten beobachtet, weil es vor allem darum ging, konnte die Familie hören, wie etwa jemand stirbt im Haus, konnten das draußen am Pool hören.
So, dann ging es um die Abstände und so, dann haben die irgendwann die Jury halt dahergeholt, was halt zwölf Vollidioten waren, so wir könnten dabei gewesen sein.
Und dann haben die die Jury gezeigt, manche haben dann so Experimente gemacht, einer hat gerufen, hallo, vor innen drin, und dann haben die draußen, haben wir das noch gehört, haben sich Notizen gemacht. Und zwei Leute standen vor einem Busch. Zwei Leute standen vor irgendeinem Busch und haben sich Notizen gemacht im fucking Garten. Hallo? Und die entscheiden dann über so ein Menschenleben. Der eine hatte Kopfhörer auf, einen Podcast gehört. Was ist denn da los? Der eine hat gehustet, wer der geworfen hat. Das machen das Leute, die keine Ahnung haben von nichts. Die stehen dann da rum und stehen vor dem Busch und machen sich Notizen auf so einem Yellow Pages-Ding. Wohingegen in Deutschland gibt es einen richtigen Sachverständigen, der fährt so einen Wagen mit einem grossen Ohr drauf, der kommt dann und horcht und dann kann der genau sagen, Massband, grosses Ohr, wird schön standardisierte Klänge, da hast du immer, hey Jude, weißt du was los ist? Das stimmt, ja, das kann ich nachvollziehen, aber dieses Jury-System ist nichts für mich, aber es ist auch nur meine Meinung. Okay, Stefan haut mal eine Meinung raus. Wenn ihr Stephans Meinung seid, dann schreibt an...
Schreibt in die Kommentare, dass ihr auch gegen das Jury-System des amerikanischen Justizsystems seid. Dann können wir vielleicht was bewegen. Zusammen können wir was bewegen. An der Stelle, falls wir selber angeklagt werden. In Amerika. Und dann einfach sagen, das ist ein unsinniges System. Ja, aber da haben wir doch sofort verloren dann, oder? Weil wenn wir das Jury-System fertig machen und dann einfach sagen dass es ein unsinniges system aber damit haben wir doch sofort verloren dann oder weil wenn wir das jury system fertig machen und dann in einen prozess kommen wobei deswegen spricht sich niemand gegen das jury system aus weil alle angst haben dass man irgendwann von der jury weil alle weil aussenmal für das jury system auch ist wenn man geladen wird dann ja ja klar aber es macht spannend dadurch glaube ich, ist auch diese amerikanische Justiz spannender und auch dramaturgisch besser ausnutzbar. Ja. Weil du kannst immer den charmanten Anwalt, der vor der Jury den emotionalen Monolog hält, zeigen, weil es hat einfach einen Sinn. Und der Beruf des Anwaltes ist auch deutlich spannender und cooler. Ach so, Better Call Saul würde in Deutschland, da guck mal, das wäre doch mal was für einen Sketch-Comedy-Kanal. Better Call Saul, lieber mal Saul anrufen.
So, das ist auch mal eine Sketch-Serie.
Alle Wortspiele verloren gegangen sind.
Das ist auch mal eine Sketch-Serie, wo du einfach sagst, wo er seinen Monolog hält und der Richter einfach sagt, ne, nach § 180 ist er schuldig.
Ciao.
Ja, der müsste heißen, Salis Gutmann.
Ach so, Salis.
It's all good man.
Salis Gutmann. Salis Gutmann. Ja, der heisst Salis Gutmann. Ach so, it's all good man. Salles Gutmann. It's all good man. Salles Gutmann. Ja, Salles Gutmann. Ja, Salles Gutmann. Und den beobachten wir auf seinem sehr langweiligen Weg Richtung Anwalt. Einfach mal schön durchballern. Schön durchballern. Wie ist es bei dir eigentlich aus? Warst du vor Gericht? Ich war schon mal vor Gericht, als ich von einem Freestyle-Karatisten verprügelt wurde. Da kann man auch immer hinzufügen, dass du für den Freestyle-Karatemeister zusammengeschlagen wurdest. Wenn ich sage, ich wurde verprügelt, dann sind doch alle sofort desinteressiert, was das für ein Fall, dass sich verprügeln. Da wollte ich aber hinzufügen, dass es jemand bei der Freestyle-Karat ausübt hat. Das war nicht mal ein Meister, kein Preis gewonnen. Nee, wo ist das eigentlich so eine Nachfrage? Der war im Verein, oder war der da? Wo ist das überhaupt eine Rolle? Vielleicht hat er das nur im YouTube-Video gesehen, keine Ahnung, aber es hat einfach Freestyle-Karate ausgeübt, aber du musst jetzt nicht so nachfragen. Aber was heißt Freestyle-Karate, der macht Karate und Rap nebenbei, oder was? Ich bin mir nicht, ja, ich glaube, es ist improvisiertes Karate. Freestyle, reimende Formen, ich bin mir nicht sicher genau. Tat jedenfalls weh, falls du das wissen willst. Ja, ja. Und dann war ich vor Gericht, ja, das stimmt. Und dann war aber, ich habe nie in der Kette jemals, hatte ich einen Anwalt oder so, komisch irgendwie, ich war noch nicht 18, kein Anwalt. und dann habe ich da jemanden angeklagt, und dann musste ich auch vor Gericht wurde ich eingeladen, hinten war ein Zuschauer, Riesentribüne, 20.000 Menschen, nicht ausverkauft, muss man leider zusagen. Die Presse hat sich angereist, was mich zu meiner Verwunderung war, das Medieninteresse entkam, sehr gering, dachte ich, zumindest kam da Lokalkompass.de oder so, kann nur noch beitkommen.
Nee.
Freestyle-Karate.de.
.org ist auch dabei.
Nur für den Jungen eingesetzt.
Und dann halt der Parteidiger und der Staatsanwalt, der auf meiner Seite war.
Du warst ja auf der Anklageseite, du hast ja den schweren Hammer der Justiz geschwungen. Ich habe den geschwungen, ja. Und nicht hochbekommen, weil er zu schwer war. Das ist schwierig. Aber meine Taktik war, ach, es war alles okay. Und ja, ich hätte da Nasenbluten. Der Staatsanwalt immer so, nein, nein. Und das war mega, weil ich habe immer gesagt, ja, ich habe da Nasenbluten, dann hat der Staatsanwalt gefragt, wo hatten Sie das Nasenbluten her, wollte natürlich, dass ich sage, dass ich den Typen beschuldige. Ich habe gesagt, ich weiß es nicht, ich habe manchmal auch so Nasenbluten, vielleicht wusste ich, ob es daher kam. Und du drehst dich um zur Jury, weiss wirklich jeder, woher man Nasenbluten hat? Und die Jury so, wir sind Zuschauer. Hatte nicht jeder von euch schon mal Nasenbluten und wusste gar nicht, woher, war es zu tief gepopelt oder im Schlaf die Nase gebrochen. Jeder von, nein, nein, hebe der den ersten Stein, der schon niemals Nasenbluten hatte und nicht dafür Rechnung tragen konnte. Sie, und dann auch so Leute ansprechen, sie, kommen Sie mal nach vorne, Leute auf die Bühne hoch. Helf dir mal auf, helft diesem Mann auf! Kommen Sie mal hoch, kommen Sie mal auf die Bühne. Auch so einfach Leute ansprechen, sie, kommen Sie mal nach vorne. Komm mal hin, auf die Bühne. Helf dir mal auf, helft diesem Mann auf! Kommen Sie mal hoch, kommen Sie mal auf die Bühne. Auch so einfach Leute ansprechen, die in der ersten Reihe in so einem Gericht. Das macht man übrigens viel zu selten. Grosse Shoutout an, Tipp, wenn ihr Zeit habt, wenn ihr Studenten seid oder sowas, setz euch mal ab und zu in ein Gericht. Ist es die beste, ist es die geilste Aktivität? Du kannst so oft coole oder wie ich sage, geile Fälle, wenn ihr Bock auf, alle stehen auf True Crime. Ihr könnt True Crime auch in eurer Stadt live gucken. Ja, aber was heißt denn True Crime? Ja, der Baum wächst über den Gartenzaun in meinem Garten. Nee, auch geile Mordfälle, Rape. Mit Mordfällen kommst du da nicht rein. Doch, Mord weiß ich jetzt nicht. Aber ich war, wir waren von der Uni aus, waren wir in einem fahrlässigen Tötungsdelikt.
Konnte man einfach dazugucken.
Das war ganz schön schlimm auch, aber da kann man zumindest zugucken dann.
Also man kann auch krasse Sachen sich anschauen hier in Deutschland im Zivilgericht.
Aber dauert sowas nicht ewig? Sind es nicht immer so 30 Verhandlungstage oder so?
Ja, gehst halt immer in den Zeitdassen und guckst, was du mitnehmen kannst am Tag. Und das sind geile Shows. Was habe ich verpasst? Ja. Psch, psch, sie mit Popcorn. Ja. Gibt es da Snacks? Nee, Popcorn wurde verboten. Gar keine Snacks? Schokolinsen. Immer die Schokolinsen. Für mich war das früher völlig normal, Schokolinsen im Kino zu essen. Mein Vater und ich haben immer Schokolinsen geholt. Popcorn war immer so, immer Schokolinsen. Hat man nicht gehabt. Auch diese unglaublich farbefrohen Schokolinsen, wo es dunkles Pink und helles Pink gab als Farben. Wo man sich denkt, schon mal was von Smarties gehört, M&Ms, Farbenfroh. Oder von Blau, der Farbe Blau. Sowas, ja. Aber nein, wir haben uns in unserer Film-Tradition dazu entschieden, unsere Schokoladen sind in Pink und helles Pink. Ja, dann kommt raus, dass der Gründer farbenblind war vielleicht. Kann sein. Kann sein. Kann nicht sein. Na, wahrscheinlich nicht. Weil wahrscheinlich ist es sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass sämtliche Mitarbeiter dieser Firma farbenblind sind oder einfach jede erdenkliche Farbe sind. Ja, und dann war meine Taktik zu sagen, naja, jeder kann mal Nasenbluten haben, weiss nicht,
weil es kommt, und dann waren alle in dem Gerichtssaal beeindruckt von meiner Ehrlichkeit, dass sich nämlich nicht dem irgendwelche Schulden in die Schuhe abschieben wollen, sondern es immer so war, ja, ich weiss jetzt auch nicht mehr genau, war auch schon lange her. Und Sie lagen auf dem Boden, Herr Tietze. Ja, oder Stand, ich we es noch nicht mehr. Bleiben wir mal bei liegen. Warum lagen Sie an diesem doch sehr kalten Herbsttag auf dem Boden, auf der Straße, auf dem Asphalt? Das kennt man doch ab und zu, dass man mal das Bedürfnis hat, sich irgendwie hinzulegen. Ich will jetzt auch niemanden irgendwie beschuldigen, dafür mich hingeworfen zu haben oder so. Man fällt, ich falle auch oft hin. Aber Sie haben hier in der Aussage geschrieben, dass kurz bevor Sie auf dem Boden lagen, der Fuss des Angeklagten, das ihr Kinn berührt hat. Meinen Sie nicht, dass das was miteinander zu tun hat? Fuss, Schmus, sag ich immer. Ich weiss ja auch. Können wir das aus dem Protokoll schreiben, streichen? Können wir das streichen? Wie schreibt man Schmus? Nein, können wir das, dass ich nachgefragt habe aus dem Protokin? Können wir das nicht? Sie schütteln mir den Kopf. Sie schütteln mir den Kopf. Haben Sie das aufgeschrieben? Können wir das raus... Okay. Glauben Sie nicht, dass diese Berührung des Fußes mit dem Kind... Können Sie die Frage umformulieren? Das ist zu kurz komplexer gestellt. Mit dieser Nicht-Konstruktion. Warum lagen Sie auf dem Boden, Herr Tietze?
Ja, akuter Anfall vor Müdigkeit.
Man kennt das doch, man hat mal, man ist manchmal groggy. Sie lagen auf der Strasse.
Man ist manchmal groggy.
Im laufenden Verkehr lagen sie auf der Strasse.
Ja, dann ist ja auch egal wo und so, die sehen ja auch, da fahre ich ja außenrum und so weiter.
Wo bin ich hingefallen, weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr so genau.
Ich war auch sehr betrunken, sehr betrunken.
Laut Aussage der Polizei haben sie geschrien, Auer, Auer, Hilfe, Auer, Schmerz, so ein Schmerz. Schmerz habe ich gerufen. Ich kann mein Kind kaum noch bewegen, der hat mir ins Gesicht geschlagen, der hat mir mit seinem Fuß ins Gesicht geschlagen. Hör auf, mich zu schlagen. Herr Tiese, warum haben Sie das? Sorry, für jemanden, der behauptet, sein Kind kann er nicht mehr...
Entschuldigung, streichen Sie das aus dem Protokoll. Warum haben Sie das bei der Polizei ausgesagt?
Ich wollte Ihnen eine spannende Story dann auch erzählen. Die haben mich gefragt mit so grossen Augen.
Wir sagen Sie Schmerz, Schmerz, Schmerz. Ich lüge nicht. Aua, der hat mich geschlagen.
Ich lüge nicht. Ich schwöre, ich lüge nicht.
Warum sollte man das sagen? Ich habe den geschlagen. Ich habe den angeklagten geschlagen. Ich bin der eigentliche Täter.
Schauen Sie mich das so an.
Keine weiteren Fragen.
Was der größte Plot ist.
Ja, und dann war ich so sehr wenig defensiv und beschuldigend, dass am Ende selbst der Anwalt, komischer Anwalt übrigens von dem Anklagten,, der dann gesagt hat, ja, Herr Tietzer war ja auch so ehrlich hier, das passt schon. Herr Richter, was auch immer Sie wollen, was mein Angeklagter. Oh, sehr gut. Und dann hat der Angeklagte ins Gefängnis gekommen. Krass. Tatsächlich. Wegen meiner, habe ich mir nachher so eingeredet, meiner Taktik. Nicht schlecht. Und dann dachte ich mir, kann man darauf stolz sein, jemanden ins Gefängnis gebracht zu haben. Schwierige Frage. Da habe ich mir ausgeredet. Was macht der heute? Machst du noch Freestyle-Karate? Nee, der ist dann im Gefängnis bekehrt worden und ist jetzt dann auf Schiefebahn geraten und so. Oh, ja, blöd passiert manchmal.. Staatsanwalt hat ja noch so ein Bounty zugeschoben. Gut gemacht. Danke. Gut gemacht. Aufs Ziel wird auch mal ein guter Anwalt. Nee, was möchtest du werden? Astronaut. Na dann. Viel Erfolg. Ah, ich nehme den selben Weg auch. Okay. Gibt es eigentlich noch so klassische ... Und sie sind den gesamten Weg nach Hause zusammengelaufen. Weil sie zufällig Nachbarn waren. Nach so einer Gerichtsverhandlung, wenn man mit dem Angeklagten dann noch nach Hause muss, nervig, wer kennt es nicht, wer kennt es nicht. Spezifische Comedy heute von Florentin Will. Kennt ihr das?
Oder wenn man aus dem Krankenhaus entlassen wird,
nach einer zwei Jahre Behandlung,
und der Chefarzt denselben Heimweg nimmt, wie man selbst,
und man den gesamten Weg... Und der Chefarzt in der ersten Reihe der Comedy-Show.
Und man läuft den gesamten Weg nach Hause.
Och, ist das blöd.
Man wird verhaftet. Florentin Will, meine Damen und der Polizist macht gerade Feierabend, der einen verhaftet hat, und läuft die gesamte zweieinhalb stündigen Heimweg neben einem schweigend Nee, bleib mal da, setz dich mal hin hin, schweigend neben einem her bis nach Hause, hör auf, bis nach Hause, oder kennt ihr an der Kasse diese Trenner, kennt ihr die Trenner, ja, mega, oder, wie Leute nervös werden, wenn man manchmal die Trenner nicht dazwischen legt, ja, okay, das war's, macht's gut, ich bin raus, das kann die, schau, quatsch, komm in die Klo, macht's gut, macht's gut, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau, macht's gut, ich bin raus! Das kannte ich! Quatsch, komm in die Kloppe, macht's gut, macht's gut, macht's gut, tschau!
Wo ist der Witz davon?
Tschau!
Der war zum ersten Mal ein Setup, was ich kannte.
Und ihr nächster Act, Stefan Tietze.
Hallo, mein Name ist Stefan, das Fun steht für Spaß.
Kennt ihr das, wie wir sind Warentrainer, wie kauft man das?
Ja!
Wie kauft man eigentlich, wie kauft dem Warentrenner? Wie kauft man eigentlich Warentrenner?
Ja, die alten Gags, alten Schoten. Ja, und das war meine Gerichtserfahrung. Rückblickend eigentlich mal gut, was mitzumachen, fand ich immer. Ja, glaube ich, ist auch gut. Was ich mal verrückt finde, gibt es ja manchmal so Character Witnesses, also Zeugen, die eigentlich gar nichts zum Fall selbst aussagen können, aber die den Angeklagten oder den Leuten, um die es geht, charakterisieren können. Also sagen können, ja, der hat mir seinen Rasen mehr geliehen, das ist ein toller Typ, so dass die Jury sagt, na dann wird er den ja nicht umgebracht haben. Eigentlich müsste man die ganze Zeit in seinem Leben daran arbeiten. Doch, mehr, aber das hatte eine lange Tradition, weil ich glaube so im Mittelalter gab es dann halt irgendwie den Leumund oder sowas, wo im Grunde nur galt, ob du in der Stadt einen guten Ruf hattest oder nicht. Und dann gab es wirklich auch ausgestellt als Dokument, dein Leumund konnte man sich ausstellen lassen, hier jemand birgt für dich, irgendwie ein Bürger kann für dich bürgen, sagt man ja auch.
Klingt ausgedacht. Weirdly convenient.
Und dann konnte man sagen, hier, zack, Läume und dann war man raus.
Worauf soll man denn gehen im Mittelalter? Haben sie den ermordet? Nein.
Ja gut, wir haben weder Fingerabdrücke noch Zeugenaussagen. Noch Luminol, wir wissen nicht, wir haben kein Luminol, wir haben keine Kameras. Ja gut, dann nicht, ciao.
Ja oder doch. Sir Mark Benecke, erhellen Sie uns. Let's love, let's ladies, nun spricht zu Ihnen Dr. Mark Benecke. Gemach, gemach, Herr Fürst, setze sich der Pöbel und schaue mein Spektakel, vergossener Lebenssaft von diesem Juden hier im Gerichtssaal rot sowie das Blut eines Christen, doch schaut her mein Zauberstaub, das Blut leuchtet wie der Heiligen Schein. Verbrenigen. Er ist ein schlimmer Hexer. Nein, so schweige er ihn. So verbrennt ihn auch. Nein, darauf wollte ich nicht genau. Nein. Na ja, es leuchtet. Sorry, es leuchtet. Können wir alle mal tiefer sprechen? Können wir alle mal tiefer sprechen? Warum müssen wir alle so hoch sprechen? Verschiedene Chemikalien reagieren mit den organischen ... ach, das ist schwierig. Es war eine harte Zeit damals. War eine andere Zeit. Könnte man auch mal machen, True Crime im Mittelalter. Man könnte so viele tolle Sachen machen, aber ihr sitzt immer nur zuhause rum und hört den Podcast. Ihr macht nix! Ihr macht nix! Schreibt ein cooles Drehbuch, dreht ein Sketch. Das war für nett. Nein da und macht nichts. Macht nix! Die machen nix! Ist doch okay, nichts zu machen. Das ist doch eher gutes Recht. Willst du denen gerade die Freiheit nehmen, nichts zu tun? Sitzen den ganzen Tag im Gerichtssaal und schauen sich hier irgendwie, hier wirklich, wo ihr richtig angeklagt. Wenn das so ein Hobby wird, dass man ab und zu ins Gericht geht, fiel ich toll. Crime ist einfach nur eine andere Art von Terrorismus. True Crime gibt dir die Möglichkeit, ins Privatleben von anderen Leuten zu schauen, einfach weil man sagt, oh, der hat was verbrochen. Oh ja, zeig mir die Wohnung. Was hatte der im Keller? Oh, komm raus, haben nichts verbrochen. Ja genau, und dann hat man einfach gesagt, oh, jetzt konnte man mal ein Nachbarhaus sehen. Schämt euch, True Crime ist schäbig. Ist nicht jede Serie auch... Ja, aber das ist ja fake. Ja, ja, aber trotzdem ... Die Daltons wohnen ja nicht wirklich in dem ... Aber befriedigt man nicht trotzdem ... Daltons, auch weird. Aber befreigt man nicht trotzdem so eine Art Voliurismus, auch wenn man es darstellt. Wie sieht es aus in Jabba's Palast? Ja. So ein bisschen. Ja, weil ich es früher nicht gewusst. Jetzt musst du es gewusst. Ich habe letztes Mal über Worte nachgedacht, dass es schon ziemlich weird ist, weil ich mache ja gerade ein Science-Fiction-Abenteuer, Pen-and-Paper-Abenteuer für Rocket Beans und da muss man sich auch viele Namen ausdenken und Namen klingen immer bescheuert irgendwie. Namen klingen immer ausgedacht. Ja, man denkt dann immer so an das, wonach sie klingen. Aber sind sie auch? Dann hast du... Sorry. Aber das ist das grosse Problem. Das grosse Beratungszone ist nämlich, weil es auch meine ... Also wenn man überlegt, wie viel Zeit als Drehbuchauter verrückt man damit, eine Szene zu schreiben oder sich Namen auszudenken, ist es sehr eindeutig, 80 % Namen ausdenken und 20 % schreiben. Und es ist absolut nicht machbar, weil Namen klingen immer ausgedacht. Was aber seltsam ist, weil Namen sind ja immer ausgedacht. Ja. Weil man überlegt sich immer Namen, die gut klingen. Aber Eltern machen ja genau das gleiche. Deswegen gibt es ja verhältnismäßig viele Alliterationen oder ich weiß nicht, irgendeinen Ausschlag in eine Richtung wird es ja schon geben. Aber Namen klingen ja immer ausgedacht. Ausgedachte Namen. Ja, aber man denkt sich immer so, das klingt so ähnlich wie, dann heisst es halt eine Figur, die heisst Boris Barguer. Und dann denkst du, das klingt wie Jaguar. Und das ist lame, weil das klingt wie Jaguar. Und das ist blöd. Aber dann habe ich mir zum Beispiel gedacht, Jabba the Hut. Das Wort Hut, Hutte, H-U-T, heisst einfach Hütte, so wie Pizza Hut. Der Hutte.
Hut heißt einfach Hütte.
Und George Lucas hat seine Figur Jabba the Hut genannt, was nichts anderes heißt als Jabba die Hütte.
Es heißt einfach Jabba die Hütte.
Also sind die Hutten nicht auch existent?
Die Hutten wirklich? Du meinst als Volksstamm irgendwo in Ruanda? Wir waren noch nicht in Ruanda, deswegen habe ich da keine Ahnung davon. Wir haben aber noch keinen Beitrag von euch aus Ruanda bekommen. Doch, wir haben Ruanda. Ja? Ja, wir haben Ruanda. Also safe, also keine weiteren Zoo Ruanda. Was wir noch brauchen ist Südafrika, bitte. Nee, da habe ich auch schon eins bekommen. Ja? Sehr gut. Elfenbeinküsse noch nicht. Aber es ist einfach komisch, weil für den englischen Hörer heißt es einfach Jabba die Hütte, weil die machen ja auch keine Artikelunterscheidung mit the.
Das heißt, Jabba the Hut kann einfach
Jabba die Hütte heißen. Aber trotzdem
klingt es cool. Man muss es einfach
mit genug Souveränität und Selbstbewusstsein einfach
behaupten. Ich komme seit Jahren nicht über den Fakt
hinweg, dass...
Und alle sind nicht so amazed wie ich
darüber, aber Pizza Hut
heißt ja Pizza
Hütte. Ja.
Aber ich habe da als Kind immer gedacht, Pizza Hut, weil da steht ja Hut und ich spreche kein Englisch, da steht Hut, Pizza Hut. Das Logo sieht aus wie ein Hut, sieht aber auch aus wie eine Hütte, weil ein Kamin drin ist, wie amazing ist das, dass alles übersetzt wurde in diesem Ding. Also natürlich nicht, aber Pizza Hut macht logotechnisch genauso viel Sinn, weil es sieht aus wie so ein Spitzer Hut, so ein Peter Pan Hut. Auf der anderen Seite heißt es aber Pizza Hut, weil es die Pizza Hütte ist. Und das Logo sieht auch aus wie eine Hütte. Ja. Aber wie genial. Es ist perfekt. Es ist das perfekte, es ist das perfekte Missverständnis.
Es ist ein Missverständnis, aus dem man auch nicht mehr rauskommt eigentlich.
Und auch aus Willen. Niemand hätte dich korrigiert.
Ich suhle mich in diesem Missverständnis seit Jahren.
Bis heute sagst du noch Pizza Hut.
Pizza Hut. Ist ein Hut.
Das ist...
Hätte diese Sätze nicht.
Es sieht aus wie ein Hut!
Ich finde das fantastisch.
Aber Pizza Hut ist eigentlich auch eine gute...
Aber dürfte man eine Firma Pizza Hut nennen in Deutschland? Weil du hast ja sehr Hut. Ich glaube nicht. Wahrscheinlich nicht, ne? Weil ja auch Wortbildmarken gesaved sind. Ich meine, du kannst ja Pizzateig so knusprig backen, dass du daraus so einen Sombrero-artigen Hut machst. Und dann trägt man den Hut und isst ihn halt so von oben runter. Und dann brauchst du auch keine Stühle und Tische, sondern du hast halt diesen Hut und isst den vom Kopf weg. Das ist genial. Ja, das ist genial. Ja, das ist genial. Das ist genial. Schon genial. Das ist wirklich genial. Congenial. Perfekt. Ein Wort, was man nicht braucht. Nein, congenial ist eines der schlimmsten Wörter der Welt. Niemand weiss es. Also ich fand, die Serie war gut, fast sogar con-gut. Oh mein, oh Gott. Con-gut. Oh mein con-gott, dass du das so formulieren musst. Wirklich grauenhaft. Das ist so ... Man weiß nicht genau, was es bedeutet. Niemand könnte das ... Das Gefühl, was man hat, wenn man mit Fingernägeln auch über eine Tafel geht. Ja. Das habe ich, wenn jemand Kongenial sagt. Ich bin oft froh, dass ich
wenig Fremdsprachige Bekannte
habe, weil ich könnte die meisten
Worte nicht erklären. Wenn mich jemand
fragt, so Paolo
aus Buenos Aires,
fragt, hey, Valentino, hey, eine Frage,
was heißt Kongenial?
Und ich sage so, ja, das ist
halt wie
Supergenial. Super, super, ja, das ist halt wie super genial, halt so super tupper, gut, par excellence, also gut, kann ich nicht erklären.
Man kann vieles nicht erklären.
Kann der Fisch erklären, was Wasser ist? Kann der Vogel erklären, was Luft ist?
Weiss der Fisch, dass er in einem weirden Aggregat lebt?
Vielleicht. Gibt es auch Unterwasserflüssigkeitsabstufe? Unterschiede, ja. Druck. Wasserdruck nimmt ja zu mit der Tiefe. Doll zu. Und das ist schon ein Unterschied, glaube ich. Deswegen, manche Fische schwimmen ja in manchen anderen Gefälden. Wollt ihr erklären, warum der Luftdruck zunimmt? Ich will übrigens vielen Dank dafür, dass ich endlich weiß, warum meine Brille beschlägt oder meine Auto beschlägt. Ja, das war so fantastisch erklärt. Dankeschön. Nee, kein Game Changer. Ich wurde oft korrigiert, aber ich nehme es trotzdem, je weniger man korrigiert wird, desto besser ist mittlerweile. Nee, du hast es natürlich eins zu eins richtig erklärt. Und ich kann aber nichts daran ändern, dass es nach wie vor ein Problem ist. Ich habe ja vorher das Problem auch schon in den Griff bekommen, wusste nur nicht, warum ich es in den Griff bekomme, weil ich habe auf alle Knöpfe gerückt im Auto, auf die man dann drückt, wenn es beschlägt, was man so lernt, so Automatismen, und dann ist es weg. Und bei der Brille muss ich halt irgendwann in so ein T-Shirt greifen, um es dann wegzumachen, in der Hoffnung, dass es dann weg ist. Und meistens kommt es dann zurück und dann ist es irgendwann weg, weil es sich an die Augentemperatur angleicht.
Aber danke, dass ich es verstanden habe. Es ist ganz merklich, in was für einer physikalischen Welt wir leben und wie wenig wir verstehen.
Ich habe zum Beispiel, ich erinnere mich noch ganz genau, weil wir es ja auch von Harald Lesch hatten, eine Folge Leschs Kosmos und der hat erzählt, man muss ja einfach hinnehmen, dass wir in einer Welt leben, wenn man mit einem Duschvorhang, einem nicht festen Duschvorhang duscht und die Dusche geht an, dann saugt sich der Duschvorhang an den Körper an. Ja. Und das ist so. Das kann man nicht ändern. Politische Systeme kann man stürzen, wirtschaftliche Systeme kann man ändern. Aber das ist halt einfach. Duschvorhang bleibt an der Kleben. Duschvorhang hänge Kleben am Menschen. Du denkst dir einfach, oh jetzt duschen und saugt er dran. Hi, ich bin sehr, schön, dass du da ... Und Harald Lesch hat gesagt, man weiß nicht warum. Was? Also, der meinte so, es gibt verschiedene Möglichkeiten, dass irgendwie dadurch, dass die Tropfen aus dem Duschkopf, weil es gibt ja einen Punkt, an dem ein Tropfen sich spaltet, also ein Tropfen startet ja als grosser Tropfen, aber je schneller er wird, desto mehr breitet er sich aus, wie so ein Franzosenhut, und dann irgendwann wird er zu gross und reißt auseinander, ja, oder wie so ein rotes Blutkörperchen, ja, es war fantastisch, ironiefrei, und dann irgendwann wird der Druck, der Luftwiderstand so hoch, dass er auseinander platzt und dann wird der Tropfen immer kleiner und auf der Erde kommen dann nur noch ganz kleine Tropfen. Tröpfchen an. Und da ist es auch so und dadurch, dass die sich irgendwann auf dieser Höhe der Hüfte aufspalten, entstehen da irgendwie so ein Vortex und Unterdruck und weird und niemand weiß es genau. So, korrigiert mich nicht, ich will keine Korrekturen haben, ich will auch nicht wissen, warum es ist, aber ich fand es so toll, dass Harald Lesch, der die Sterne und die Sonne verstanden hat, nicht versteht, warum ihm morgens der Duschvorgang schön am Bein klebt. Ich fand das toll. Die Welt ist ein Mysterium. Genau wie es vor allem noch nicht, wenn man etwas in Wasser giesst, also zum Beispiel Wasser in Wasser, um mal Phantasie nicht zu sehr zu beanspruchen. Er hat eine Tasse Wasser und ein Becken voll Wasser und er kippt langsam das Wasser ins Wasser. Könnt ihr mir folgen? Ja. Dann gibt es vorne so eine kleine Bugwelle. An der Tasse oder am ...?
Nee, unten, wo das Wasser aufs Wasser trifft. Jetzt spätestens wäre es sinnvoll, Zweifeligkeiten zu haben.
In Wasser A trifft auch Wasser B. In einem glatten, geraden Strahl. Und vorne entsteht so eine kleine Bugwelle.
Niemand weiß, es kommt vorne wieder so raus. N niemand weiss warum, wo? Am Wasser B oder was?
Angenommen, du schüttest Milch in Kaffee von oben, dann kommt Milch rein und da wo der Strahl Milch auf den Kaffee trifft, ist vorne, Weil, ne, in die Richtung, in die die Milch fliesst, du machst es ja ja nicht gerade wahrscheinlich, sondern du bist ja so ein bisschen schräg und dann kommt die Milch rausgeschossen. Vorne entsteht so eine kleine Welle vor dem Auftreffen und da geht Milch quasi hoch und dann in den Kaffee rein. Niemand weiß, warum diese Bugwelle entsteht. Die macht keinen Sinn, theoretisch. Ich muss hier einfach reinfließen. Auch hier, korrigiert mich nicht.
Keine Korrekturen bitte, wir wollen keine Korrekturen.
Aber es steht irgendwo in der Liste der ungelösten physikalischen Fragezeichen, sind teilweise noch manche Probleme trivial drauf. Es gibt auch viele Mathematik-Oh, ich war mal so arrogant, weil ich so ein paar Yale-Universitäts-Irgendwo kann man dann so, im Internet kann man ja auch Mathematik-Vorlesungen sich anschauen und so weiter. Und da habe ich ein paar verstanden, da war ich so stolz drauf. Und dann habe ich mir den Wikipedia-Artikel der ungelösten mathematischen Probleme durchgelesen. Und ich dachte, jetzt bin ich bereit. Jetzt kann ich es nicht mehr, weil ich ja denke ja von outside the box so, ich bin ja nicht in einem Mathematik-System, ich komme von außen, komme die, da kann man das das bestimmt, mein Mind denkt anders als ich, das Problem anders. Und dann habe ich mir diese Liste der ungelösten mathematischen Probleme durchgelesen, in der Hoffnung, eines davon lösen zu können. Du kriegst einen Millionen Dollar. Ich glaube ja. Die sind Millennium-Probleme, ja? Ja, genau, die sind dotiert. Und? Nichts. Nichts geschafft? Nee. Auch mal angefangen, zumindestindest mal das Problem aufgeschrieben auf dem eigenen Blatt. Ja. Dazu bin ich gekommen. Welches hast du dir ausgesucht? Weich nicht mehr. Aber das, wo du dachtest, das schaffe ich. Das, was einfach klingt. Ja. Warum kann man nicht Summe N ausrechnen von Primzahlen? Warum sind Primzahlen, warum sind die Abstände nicht immer regelmäßig? Primzahlen sind schwierig. Ja, dann hängst du da am Blatt Papier und denkst dir, wofür mache ich das eigentlich? Wem würde ich was beeindrucken? Wem würde ich da jetzt was beweisen? Mir selbst? Man weiss nicht. Wir werden es nie erfahren, aber wir wünschen euch trotzdem weiterhin eine fantastische Woche. Viel Spaß. Beweist ihr es bei jemandem? Beweist ihr, ja genau, haut mal was raus, haut mal was raus, holt ihr eine Million Euro und kauft euch davon ganz viele Podcast-Ufo-Socken. Denn die Weihnachtszeit kommt, es wird warmer, es wird kälter, es wird immer kälter. Wir haben es geprobt, das ist falsch auch gesagt, oh Gott. Beschützt eure Füsse, das wichtigste Körperteil. Und geht mal ins Gericht. Ja, geht ins Gericht. Und schaut euch mal an, was um euch herum so passiert für grausames Zeug. Geht ins Gericht, tragt ein Podcast-Ufo-T-Shirt und schaut, ob ihr andere Leute mit Podcast-Ufo-T-Shirts findet. Und findet so richtig so Gerichts-Ultra-Gruppen, so Fangruppen, die sich dann so wirklich so Gesangsküren. Ja, diese Sportereignisse, die auch so anfeuern und so. Transparente hochhalten und so und ja.
Ja, aber nicht, dass es zu politisch wird.
Nee, still, aber entschieden.
Aber höflich.
Macht's gut.
Schöne Woche.
Schöne Woche wünscht euch.
Wir heben ab, macht's gut.
Ciao.